see in australia i don't know what's  happened here but  uh one of our better universities has  been tracking confidence in the  political system and democracy now since  1970.  a staggeringly low number of australians  have confidence that our democracy is  working properly if you don't trust at  the system  in fact if you it's bad enough not to  trust the people in it at any given  point in time if you no longer trust the  institutions that's really serious  if you don't even believe in understand  and trust the principles behind the  institutions  of freedom then you really are in  trouble so trust is critically important  you don't build trust by calling people  names